uh the support visit which is already
over
oh some Berlin
Berlin 2424
okay but that's really surprising
because I should claim copyright here
because I was the first that one was the
first one to have like 15 games into the
database as black you know because uh
you know people they know that I was
playing to Berlin uh for and now 15
years maybe I'm playing the Berlin and
people you know this they notice about
that if they want to do they can go for
for that and so I had many many games
before it was very popular in this
online games so you're you're rightly
very proud of that I can tell that was
black I was black all the time I I think
I don't have a single wide game here but
uh I had many black games and actually
it's uh yeah when people they see that
and they feel okay maybe your door is
okay then then they go for it so I don't
know what's um very surprising decision
well it depends uh who is playing Vegeta
in the last uh and I've just looked
Anton okay he's white and he has to win
yeah makes sense yeah well makes some
sense I don't know it depends I mean
maybe he's thinking that
um who does Gary play in the wall sir
and Gary has black against Arjun
yeah
I don't know yeah I agree with you
actually maybe it's not
[Music]
um
yeah no maybe it's not it's not it's not
great for video actually